There are countless reasons to get hyped up
for Spider-Man: Far From Home there's the
web-slinging action, the international setting,
and getting to see what comes next in the
MCU after Avengers: Endgame.
But if you think that the excitement stops
when the final shot of Far From Home fades
to black, you're sorely mistaken.
We can confirm that there's a surprise cameo
included in a mid-credits scene that will
make longtime Spider-Man fans totally freak
out.
It goes without saying that we're going to
get into major spoilers for Spider-Man: Far
From Home from this point on.
Those hoping to walk into theaters with a
clear head and no context, turn away.
Everyone else, stick with us as we reveal
the epic cameo.
The mid-credits scene takes Peter and MJ back
to New York City, where a news report plays
out on a huge screen to a crowd of bystanders.
It's up on that screen that fans will see
a familiar face: none other than The Daily
Bugle founder J. Jonah Jameson.
What's even better about this cameo is that
it isn't just any actor playing Jameson in
the Spider-Man: Far From Home mid-credits
scene.
It's J.K. Simmons, who famously portrayed
the crazed newsman in director Sam Raimi's
original Spider-Man film trilogy from the
2000s.
Simmons last sported Jameson's signature toothbrush
mustache and flattop haircut in 2007's Spider-Man
3, meaning his cameo appearance in Far From
Home is the first time in over a decade that
he's assumed the role for a live-action project.
In true Jameson fashion, the Daily Bugle blowhard
is in a huge huff over Spider-Man's antics
in the Far From Home mid-credits scene.
The news report includes an exclusive clip
originally released by the "controversial
news website" TheDailyBugle.net, which shows
Peter giving orders to quote "execute them
all."
This is obviously doctored, as we know Spider-Man
would never do such a thing.
Still, many New Yorkers take it at face value,
believing that the formerly-friendly neighborhood
hero was the one who orchestrated the attack
on London.
The events of Spider-Man: Far From Home reveal
the actual perpetrator and it definitely isn't
Spidey.
Jameson pushes a contrasting narrative: that
Spider-Man is a menace, and the villain of
Far From Home is really a hero.
"Who is Spider-Man?
He's a criminal!  That's who he is.
A vigilante!
A public menace!
What's he doing on my front page?"
Many fans speculated that Spider-Man: Far
From Home would include a cameo from J. Jonah
Jameson, with some outlets even running early
reports that it was definitely true.
Though it was difficult to prove the claims
at that time, we can now say with certainty
that they were accurate.
Even without any leaks and rumors and theories,
there was a big piece of evidence to suggest
a J. Jonah Jameson cameo in Spider-Man: Far
From Home: Simmons' attendance at the film's
world premiere in Hollywood on Wednesday,
June 26.
Considering Simmons wasn't on the red carpet
for the premiere of Spider-Man: Homecoming
because he wasn't in that movie, Marvel super
fans began putting two and two together: Simmons'
Jameson would probably be in Far From Home
in some capacity.
Turns out that they were right.
Though the J. Jonah Jameson cameo in Far From
Home is sure to make audiences scream and
shout in their seats, it's only the start
of the after-credits fun.
Far From Home also includes a post-credits
scene that confirms a popular theory fans
have discussed for months on end.
We won't spoil it for you here, but anyone
who has seen Captain Marvel and speculated
that a certain element from that superhero
flick might pop up in Far From Home will go
nuts over the film's post-credits stinger.
Look forward to seeing J. Jonah Jameson in
Spider-Man: Far From Home when the film swings
into theaters on July 2.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Spider-Man:
Far From Home are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.